équipés de lunettes à vision nocturne
ces hommes du peloton de surveillance et
d'intervention de la gendarmerie scrute
les vignes durant quatre heures ils vont
se poster sur différentes parcelles
leurs objectifs
le flagrant délit de vol de raisin
autre patrouille autre technique ici on
ne cherche pas la discrétion mais plutôt
la dissuasion
cet équipage de la brigade territoriale
de beaune sillonnent les vignes en
voiture siglée tous feux allumés d'abord
protéger bien légitime des viticulteurs
contribué à dissuader la commission
d'atteintes aux biens du type de ceux
qui ont été perpétrées l'an passé et
bien entendu le cas échéant sur un
flagrant délit procédé à
l'interpellation de ce qui s'en serait
rendu coupable avec quatre délits
recensés l'année dernière le vol de
raisin est un phénomène plutôt rare dans
le vignoble bourguignon
hormis un cas un morceau concernant un
demi hectare soit plus d'une tonne de
raisin les lartin représentent des
petites quantités
christophe chemin été victime d'un vol
qui aurait pu passer inaperçue c'était
prévu et de raisin par pied pas de
feuilles par terre c'est à dire que le
lendemain si j'envoyais qui peuvent en
danger on s'aperçoit de rien c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu quelques vols
quelques vols l'année dernière 400 vols
dans la région sur mer chaumont cli tout
ça mais il ya sûrement eu d'autres vols
compas été
vu par les chefs d' équipes de
vendangeurs et parce que en fait on voit
rien du tout là c'est le hasard que j'ai
pris la personne en flagrant délit co
des vols souvent traumatisant pour les
victimes d'autant que les auteurs
seraient également des viticulteurs nous
convoitises certainement lié un
enchaînement de mauvaises années
pour nous c'est une vraie bénédiction
parce que on ne peut pas se passer de
nos raisins les villes ne sont pas
entouré de clôtures notre raisin pense
ou les cèpes et il faut donc les
protéger en 2017 les vendanges sont plus
abondantes mais on sait que la côte d'or
est un îlot de bonheur en termes de
quantité et de qualité
comparé aux autres régions il peut y
avoir des tentations
les patrouilles seront en place jusqu'à
la fin des vendanges
le dispositif pourrait être étendu à
d'autres vignobles de la région